welcome to this video playing endless
fighter let us flag now he changed
flexor quite quite a number of times
still no name right okay let's see what
I got for four out of ten against the
sky Jack no draw okay let's see what is
doing against my my pet variation
against the Scotch ya bish should be
three are taking on c6 other the moves
now this is uncommon yeah well what
should I do here it's probably not very
dangerous in any case but what do I play
Knight f6 he might take play if I've hmm
favorite move coming edge for yeah maybe
come on let's do that it's a bit a bit
cheeky but can probably be played and d
6 plus my idea I need to cover a 5mm
that I can that I can take the night
there once it if it decides to go down
might be three Bishop you 60 certainly
okay maybe you can play Bishop e3
m-maybe
hmm the idea being three nights is six
and bishop or kids taking immediately ok
I want to play Knight f6 castles nigera
this somewhat through looking attack but
very often I really got got the good
positions with this this kind of stuff
Knight f6 Knight f3 probably queen age
five and Andy five guys might happen
should I play 97 maybe instead or Bishop
g4 hmm
I can't play 97 that's not not bad
Knight f3 queen age 50 K shouldn't be
too bad for me by this Queen salty to
age for some sort of one of my favorite
move so I'd like to get it in but it's
probably not objectively so great maybe
we should be to something like that
could be an idea to get this discovery
yeah but it's probably not necessary if
I go Bishop g4 you will probably play
but should be two anyway hmm not clear
what white sir plan should be him and I
mean in general okay so he does not mind
to trade Bishop g4 young maybe maybe why
not f3 Bishop d7 should be okay for
black
I don't think he was threatening to take
on c6 but the bishop on g4 really wasn't
destined to be there forever anyway okay
just castles I guess
and now yeah probably i should move this
in the ship's sometimes threatening c5
are not really the seven Hanks but
almost ninety six to e5 probably Bishop
e2 maybe I should should have g6
available so centralized g6 for the
Queen I mean if he plays Bishop e2
yeah so it still feels like I should be
quite okay in don't see anything
terrible happening to me okay so he does
not mind this trade yeah I also don't
mind really if he if he takes on b6
strengthening my pawn structure maybe
it's still 95 he's taking ages here I
mean I am slow but this is probably head
probably even slower Bishop g4 or just
move this I thought so 25 might be good
just attacking the pawn if he takes a be
there is also an H way okay so night f4
maybe yeah why not let's just get the
night in there in the game
platter that's a good boo sugar so maybe
rookie 5 this kind of stuff will croak
here look h 50 it looks it looks
dangerous Queen age six I have yeah okay
i can now take which is of course at
least a draw but it looks it looks like
there should be maybe more okay but
before i fall in love with this move
maybe I have something better you what
about Quinn two is six just threatening
queen age three that's that's actually a
good move here I think the Queen and
this this Bishop won't be six is the big
problem I had threatened to take on g3
here Queen h3 yeah here's a now he has
to play this move and let's see maybe I
can way I can do something here g5 is
too crude probably hmm maybe I maybe I
always timate at this should g4
intending Bishop f3 he's got should be
to time warning
there is no direct win here it seems
it's disappointing really f5 Bishop g2
okay d 5 maybe so that I can that can
retreat if i go to e6 this isn't really
a good retreat d 552 to e6 what the heck
yeah i lost the threat here he was he
was really in totally bad shape here and
this is still still okay probably but of
course now just very messy I want to
want to go to c6 Queen g3 well sort of
gone to h5 probably to a five I mean and
don't have any time oops check
ah he's he's tricked me ok I have what
the heck check yeah yeah and this is
just frustrating this erotic time
controller yet again and whatever I mean
it it was simply a simply very good for
black and I wonder I wonder if I had to
win here I mean I probably should have
had to win yeah look takes a choice and
is indeed Jaden checkmate you yeah
actually should she for our come on what
is this I mean Bishop Bishop h3 I mean
why don't I see this I mean this is very
simple Queen g4g to mate and also would
have been a very logical conclusion to
the game ok ok I mean here black also
winds but it's not so it's not so so
easy round here I mean winning is a
compass on +1 of course I mean after to
Bishop and bishops and white is totally
uncoordinated so it's clear that that
I'm better I can also just take a tool
but here we are in the in the twenty20
second territory and we shouldn't really
analyze this white now got got in a lost
position again and yeah well okay
there's no need to look at this really I
mean interesting is this part of the
game where I think he made some some
probably unsuccessful maneuvers I'm in
here this is just just good for black
now and this is this way to defend was
this year was quite quite clearly bad I
mean
he must if he plays the cmas try Knight
f3 Angus Bishop g4 Quincy one stuff like
that I mean this is very very good for
black but not as bad and doesn't the
game this is really this is a direct
made I did not just take that I mean
it's this is also a good practical
choice you have the draw in hand and
probably you have a win I mean okay just
I thought that this wins actually I
didn't really see that this keep things
together for the moment I thought that
this was this was winning yeah okay
anyway ah thanks for watching